im Kalten Krieg der 1950er Joe McCarthy
der Kommunistenjäger beide folgen morgen
20 Uhr bei Phoenix
[Musik]
Unter den Linden das politische
Streitgespräch aus dem Herzen der
Hauptstadt
kontrovers sachlich und mit genügend
Zeit für jedes Argument
der konstruktive Meinungsstreit Unter
den Linden morgen
22:15 Uhr bei Phoenix
[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Jörg Schönenborn ich willkommen schön
dass Sie dabei sind an diesem
Sonntagmittag die lange erwartete
ukrainische Frühjahrsoffensive hat
begonnen Berichte darüber gibt es viele
über
rückeroberte Dörfer im Osten über
zerstörte oder eroberte westliche Panzer
im Netz welche Informationen wirklich
überprüfbar belastbar sind das
besprechen wir gleich sicher ist aber
bei dieser Frühjahrsoffensive geht es
nicht nur um die Frage wie weit ist der
Ukraine gelingt die russischen Angreifer
von ihrem Staatsgebiet zu verdrängen es
geht auch darum ob kampfeswelle und
Moral für den nächsten Winter noch
erhalten bleiben und ob die westliche
Unterstützung durch die NATO aufrecht
erhalten bleibt unser Thema heute im
Presseclub ukrainische Offensive
entscheidet sich jetzt der Krieg und ich
freue mich sehr auf diese Gäste Simone
Brunner ist bei uns sie ist redak im
österreich-büro der Wochenzeitung Die
Zeit berichtet seit rund zehn Jahren aus
der Ukraine und aus Russland ich begrüße
Helga Schmidt sie leitet das
hörfunkstudio vom westdeutschen und
Norddeutschen Rundfunk in Brüssel
herzlich willkommen John Mireille Leiter
des investigativ Ressorts beim
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland und als
krisenreporter immer wieder und auch
kürzlich in der Ukraine und herzlich
willkommen Viktor Funk er ist Redakteur
im Politik Ressort von table Media macht
für seine Leserinnen und leser-
Herr Funk lassen Sie uns mal anfangen
welche Informationen haben wir denn 1000
km Front was wissen wir über das was in
den letzten Tagen dort geschehen ist
wir wissen vor allen Dingen dass wir
sehr wenig wissen es gab letzte Woche
hat der Chef des ukrainischen
Geheimdienstes und eindrucksvolles Video
veröffentlicht indem er einfach nur
geschwiegen hat ich glaube 30 Sekunden
lang einfach nur geschwiegen und das war
so seine Botschaft darüber was die
Ukraine bereit ist an Informationen
preiszugeben über das was passiert und
überwiegend beziehen wir wahrscheinlich
alle zusammen unsere Nachrichten das aus
Telegramm Kanälen aus russischsprachigen
ukrainischen telegram-kanälen und dort
gibt es natürlich sehr viel
widersprüchliche Angabe man feiert vor
allen Dingen Erfolge und sagt halt dass
der Gegner halt ja wahnsinnig hohe
Verluste führt aber ob das ist das ist
im Moment wirklich ein Stock an dem
Nebel 30 Sekunden schweigen als
Statement für die Öffentlichkeit haben
wir was wissen sie mehr also ich habe
gestern mit einem ukrainischen Offizier
an der Front telefoniert noch der 17
Klasse ja das Oberstleutnant Sergej
ausschuk vor den Grenztruppen und ähm
der hat vor überhöhten Erwartungen im
Westen gewann an dieser offensiver der
hat ganz klar gesagt dass das wird nicht
das Kriegs Ende herbeiführen der hat der
das probierter Historiker der hat gesagt
wenn er das jetzt mit dem Ersten
Weltkrieg vergleicht dann würde er sagen
2016 sind wir ungefähr danach dauerte
der Krieg bekanntlich noch zwei Jahre
und ich hatte ihn auch gefragt nachdem
an also ob die Truppen optimistisch sind
wieder das Gefühl ist und sagte die sind
realistisch und Optimismus haben haben
nur noch die Leute sagt er die nicht
schon an Kampfhandlungen in der Ukraine
Ukraine teilgenommen haben dem Rest sei
das abhanden gekommen das ist ein
chassive ja ganz kurz verbracht gut also
davor dass Einstellung jetzt die noch
die Ukraine halten ja Frau Brunner wie
bewerten Sie die bisher vorliegenden
Informationen ich habe es gesagt
angeblich rückeroberte Dörfer angeblich
zerstörte westliche Panzer also wieder
Kollege funkt schon sagte also es ist
glaube ich wir wissen dass wir sehr
wenig Wissen das ist zumindest also es
ist eine riesengroße Frontlinie die da
geht also 1000 Kilometer es gibt wohl an
mehreren Stellen harte Kämpfe also das
gibt von von viel also gibt es viele
Berichte darüber ähm aber was man glaube
ich sagen kann ist das jetzt also nicht
einen großen Tuch gegeben hätte dann
irgendwo einer der Frontlinien weil das
wäre dann natürlich irgendwie ähm
berichtet worden oder das das lässt sich
dann auch in so einem informationsvakuum
glaube ich schwer vertuschen also es ist
alles glaube ich noch sehr statisch und
im Beginn sie können die Rätsel auflösen
sie sitzen nämlich am Platz der NATO in
Brüssel wo ganz sicher alle relevanten
Informationen verfügbar sind ja deshalb
fand ich es interessant zu hören dass
man da auch Fragezeichen bei den
Beobachtern der Ukraine sieht das deckt
sich genau mit den Einschätzungen in
Brüssel im Hauptquartier der NATO da hat
man sich mal angeschaut wie Kriege zu
Ende gegangen sind in den vergangenen
Jahren Jahrzehnten und da zeigt sich
dass jeder Krieg der länger als ein Jahr
dauert dann wirklich noch mal sehr lange
dauert und die Militär sein dass ein
abnutzungskrieg mit heißen fahren Phasen
offensichtlich erleben wir gerade eine
Phase mit furchtbaren Gefechten und dann
kommen auch wieder ruhigere Phasen es
geht um Quadratkilometer Hektare aber
nicht um wirklich große Gelände Gewinne
und das kann länger dauern da davon geht
man in Brüssel aus danke an alle die
auch heute wieder im Netz dabei sind in
unseren Kanälen bei Tagesschau und
presseclub.de danke für Ihre
Rückmeldungen die mich auch hier im
Studio erreichen
eine Frage die in vielen Variationen
immer wieder auftaucht glaubt jemand in
der Runde dass diese Offensive den Krieg
entscheiden wird nein
nein also ich glaube sie können die
Ukraine eine bessere Position bringen
ich glaube was passieren kann ist also
wenn die jetzt im Idealfall die Truppen
an das asophische Meer vordringen
könnten zum Beispiel die Krim also
russische Stellung auf der Krim unter
Beschuss nehmen könnten das womöglich
dann der Druck auf Putin so wächst dass
er sich zu Verhandlungen gezwungen sieht
das ist wahrscheinlich schon das der
beste Fall der denkbar ist aber
selbstverhandlungen ehrlich gesagt bin
ich überzeugt bringen gar nichts weil
weil Putin diese Zeit einfach dazu
nutzen wird sich wieder in Stellung zu
bringen und diesen Krieg vorzusetzen
Aussicht der Ukrainer geht der kriegt ja
nicht seit dem 24.02 letzten Jahres
sondern seit 2014 mit den russischen
Separatisten im Don Bass und der
völkerrechtion der Krim und Putin
solange Putin im Amt ist und die Ukraine
nicht in der NATO bin ich überzeugt wird
die Ukraine nie sicher sein dann lassen
Sie uns mal helfen unserem Publikum zu
verstehen was ist das Ziel und was ist
das Vorgehen bei dieser Offensive der
Ukraine es ist ja seit Monaten das Thema
alle Waffenlieferungen und
panzerlieferung des ganz Boden unter
anderem auch immer damit in Zusammenhang
gebracht dass wenn geliefert wird die
Ukraine zurückschlagen Teile des Landes
befreien kann also was ist das Vorgehen
was ist das Ziel verbunden natürlich
also ich glaube es ist das das Ziel
einfach so viel Gebiete wie möglich zu
befreien und Zeit ist natürlich ein
wichtiger Faktor also ich erinnere mich
letztes Jahr gab es ja auch natürlich
offensiven und zurückeroberungen bei
karkiff z.B oder Becher Sohn und je
länger natürlich diese Gebiete auch
unter russischer Besatzung sind desto
schwieriger wird es da auch die wieder
zu integrieren also ich glaube für die
Ukraine ist einfach Zeit spielt eine
extrem große Rolle und ähm deswegen je
früher desto besser diese Offensive wo
man ja sagen muss das hat sich ja sehr
verzögert wir haben ja von früher als
Offensive gesprochen eigentlich schon
seit dem Winter sprechen wir davon dass
also in Erwartung diese Offensive bis
nächste Woche ist noch früher ja ja aber
wurde schon sehr sehr lange erwartet und
natürlich hat das auch den Russen Zeit
gegeben sich darauf vorzubereiten sich
einzugraben ihre Linien zu verstärken
also das ja möglicherweise jetzt auch
irgendwie wieder Grund ist dass das
jetzt nicht vielleicht doch nicht so
schnell voran kommt wie man das gehofft
hat was ist das Vorgehen was ist das
Ziel
gerade gesagt alles was so länger ist
ein Jahr dauert verfestigt sich das ja
und verlängert sich und ich glaube man
muss das schon in dieser recht statische
beziehungsweise so statisch war die
Situation auch nicht da es gab halt
relativ viele Kämpfe wenn man Bach mutig
anguckt ja beide Seiten haben sich
massiv auf Bach Mut konzentriert da gab
es unglaubliche Verluste wir wissen mehr
hat über die Verluste sozusagen auf der
russischen Seite oder auf der seltene
Seite wie die ukrainischen wissen sehr
wenig aber man muss dann natürlich auch
irgendwie jetzt Bewegung in das ganze
hier bringen weil sonst auch die
Situation sich immer stärker halt
verlängert einfach so wie das war dann
geht es ja nicht nur darum dass auch
administrativ politisch die eroberten
Gebiete irgendwie immer stärker in
Russland integriert werden sondern
einfach die rein militärische
Befestigung die wurde immer stärker und
stärken und stärker und es gab die
Initiative die Ukraine letzten Herbst
übernommen hat und sicherlich bisschen
in den Winter hinein hat hatte die hat
sich dann einfach wieder zum Nachteil
hat gewandelt weil Zeit einfach auf
Putins Seite ist das ist halt das
Hauptproblem an dieser ganzen Geschichte
die
also verständlich einerseits aus
demokratische Perspektive verständlich
aber aus militärische Perspektive nicht
verständlich ist langsame Unterstützung
der Ukraine führte halt einfach dazu
dass die Russen sich immer stärker und
immer wieder schneller vorbereiten
können auf das was da laut angekündigt
wird im Westen und das ist deswegen ist
die Situation ist einfach schwieriger
und was die Ukraine im Moment versucht
ist einfach ein durchbruchsmöglichkeiten
zu finden die aber die weiß nicht
vielleicht sehen die Militärs werden ich
sehe die nicht aber was sehr Funk gerade
sachlich die Zeit ist glaube ich nicht
nur also die Spiel für Putin das glaube
ich auch aber das nicht nur auf dem
Schlachtfeld sondern eben auch
international wenn wir denken dass
nächstes Jahr Wahlen in den USA sind wo
Trump die dann Kandidat ist der dann ein
Putin Sympathisant ist oder kann das gar
nicht anders sagen mit dem zweitausend
Kandidaten Moment ist der von einem
territorialen des Putin in Europa
gesprochen hat und ich bin sicher das
Gute noch diese Wahlen hofft weil wenn
man sich anguckt das
Meinungsforschungsinstitut hat
vorgestern meine ich noch mal eine neue
Umfrage herausgegeben die die
Prozentzahl der Amerikaner die die sagen
wir liefern zu viel wir als Amerikaner
liefern zu viel Hilfe das war zu
Kriegsbeginn lag die bei 7% jetzt bei 28
Prozent und bei den Republikanern ist
dieser Wert gestiegen von 9 Prozent auf
44 Prozent und auch schon vor der Wahl
wird das im US-Wahlkampf eine große
Rolle spielen wo mit Sicherheit
zumindestrepublikaner hat thematisieren
werden warum sie eigentlich so viel
bezahlen für einen Krieg in Europa was
übrigens eine völlig legitime Frage ist
warum die schon wieder den Löwenanteil
zahlen und wir uns wieder darauf
verlassen dass die Amerikaner unsere
Sicherheit Regeln wie schon in Bosnien
und so weiter aber ich glaube wir werden
da unter Druck kommen als Europäer und
werden uns darauf einstellen müssen dass
wir da mehr Verantwortung übernehmen
müssen als wir das bislang tun
das wissen die Europäer ich glaube das
haben die auch inzwischen verstanden
dass es nicht angehen kann dass die
Amerikaner ein Vielfaches an Soldaten
stellen auch an Geld bezahlen und Waffen
liefern zu können in die Ukraine
bei putin war ja eines der Kriegsziele
ich finde das darf man nicht vergessen
den Westen einzubinden in diesen Krieg
und das war neben der Eroberung der
Ukraine weil er sagt das ist eigentlich
kein richtige Nation das gehört zu
Russland war das ja das zweitwichtigste
Ziel und ich denke daran arbeitet er
auch weiter er will dass der Westen
stärker interveniert er will dass der
besten Truppen schickt in die Ukraine
und er will auch dass sie den die
Entscheidung treffen die Ukraine zum
NATO Mitglied zu machen damit er einen
anderen anpack noch mal diesen
politischen Fragen kommen ich will noch
mal versuchen wir wissen wenig aber ich
glaube es gibt ein paar Fragen die wir
zumindest noch versuchen müssen zu
beantworten die Zerstörung des kachowa
Staudamms ist nicht nur eine humanitäre
Katastrophe vor anderthalb Wochen
sondern hat mutmaßlich auch Auswirkungen
es wird gerätselt und niemand am Tisch
weiß ob es ein Unfall oder russische
Sabotage war welche Auswirkungen hat das
und wie verändert das die Lage auf dem
Schlachtfeld also natürlich wissen wir
nicht was passiert ist am Stauraum aber
man muss die Folgen kennen wir natürlich
also das ist ja zwei Drittel des
überflutungsgebiets ist auf der russisch
kontrollierten Seite also weil das ja
topografisch auch eigentlich
Niederlande sehr stark davon betroffen
also trotzdem gehe ich eher davon aus
also das Russland also dafür
verantwortlich ist weil die das einfach
schon seit mehr als einem Jahr
kontrollieren diesen Stauraum und ob man
die nicht einfach so von außen springen
kann also ob es jetzt ein Unfall war
oder gezielt dass da gehen die Meinungen
auseinander aber die Auswirkungen sind
wohl
kurzfristig natürlich also das ist das
schwer wird also in diese Richtung
vorzudringen also weil das jetzt
überflutet ist aber ob das langfristig
jetzt wirklich große Auswirkungen hat
militärisch also eine Katastrophe
natürlich aber militärisch und ich finde
es zeigt ja auch dass so ein Krieg nicht
nur durch Kampfpanzer und Haubitzen und
Flugzeuge entschieden wird sondern auch
durch solche gezielten Schläge nicht nur
wegen der Umweltkatastrophe sondern weil
zigtausende Menschen ihr ihr ihre
Wohnung verlieren und auch getötet
werden das gleiche hatten wir bei
Anschlägen auf die Energieversorgung
also das gehört auch zu diesem Krieg
Putins das darf man nicht weiter genau
das ist auch eine zeigt auch die
Radikalisierung zu Beginn ging es ja
noch darum wie also Putin hat ja davon
gesprochen er möchte die Ukraine
befreien von vermeintlichen Nazis das
ist das Bruder folgt es wird niemand
drunter leiden und jetzt mittlerweile
geht ja die russische Kriegstaktik schon
so weit also gezielt wirklich die
Zivilbevölkerung anzugreifen genau das
weiß natürlich eine sehr spektakuläre
Sache für dich ehrlich gesagt auch ist
undenkbar halte das die Ukraine dafür
verantwortlich sind dass sie ihr eigenes
Land so so verwüsten ihre eigene
Bevölkerung töten aber was ein bisschen
untergeht in der akademischen Diskussion
oder oder abgesehen von so spektakulären
Geschichten ist dieses Leid der
Zivilbevölkerung dieses tägliche also
ich war im März in Person das ist fast
schon abenteuerlich da stehen sie als
Journalisten mit splitterschutzweste und
Helm und Verbandspäckchen irgendwie auf
dem Markt wo die anderen Leute natürlich
ganz normal stehen und ihre Sachen
verkaufen während konstant die russische
Artillerie diese Stadt beschießt von der
anderen Seite vom Lipo aus und sie
kommen sich vor wie in einem komischen
Film weil sie denken können dass
beschießt heißt was genau haben sie da
erlebt ist wir hören dieses Grollen das
und das war jetzt nicht das Viertel in
dem wir waren das geschossen wurde
dieser Markt wurde wo wir standen wurde
wenige Wochen später das ist eine
Granate eingeschlagen dann und aber das
waren dann das waren in dem Fall andere
Viertel aber die Russen beschießen seit
sie das seit sie sich daraus
zurückgezogen haben vom anderen die pro
Seite aus mit Artillerie Zivilisten und
das ist ja nicht nur nicht nur dort so
und sie stehen dann da und diese
Verkäufer die sind so dran gewöhnt dass
man sie darauf ansprechen muss ob die
das eigentlich auch hören oder ob man
das jetzt und das ist schon also das ist
jetzt nicht so das ist so knallt wie das
da in bachmut äh das tat wenn sie ganz
in der Front sind aber sie hören dieses
wollen die ganze Zeit
und das ist womit die Leute leben oder
in slowianz wo sie abends durch Straßen
fahren wo es überhaupt kein Licht mehr
gibt wo es wirkt als wären das komplette
geisterstätte wo sie nachts sieben Mal
Luftalarm haben also wo sie am Ende die
App ausschalten weil sie natürlich nicht
sieben Mal in den Keller Rennen am Ende
aber das ist einfach ein Terror der
dagegen die Zivilbevölkerung gerichtet
ist dass ich denke das Putin tatsächlich
von dem Kriegsverbrecher Tribunal gut
aufgehoben werden ich versuche mal ihre
Lagebeschreibung zusammen zu fassen also
das von dieser Offensive jetzt schnell
der entscheidende Schlag für diesen
Krieg ausgeht sagen sie nein das ganze
komme später als erwartet oder als
günstig für die Ukraine die Russen
hätten sehr viel Zeit gehabt
Verteidigungsstellungen aufzubauen
abgelesen dass der Halo Trust der
überlanden Informationen weltweit
sammelt von einem industriellen Verlegen
von Minen
spricht
wo sind dann also das klingt alles sag
mal wenig aussichtsreich wo sind die
Chancen die die Ukraine jetzt haben also
was wäre ein aus ukrainischer Sicht
gutes Szenario was jetzt passieren kann
also ich glaube das Problem ist mit der
Sprengung des Staudamms und da gibt es
ja schon relativ sichere Erkenntnisse
dass es eine Sprengung gegeben hat ja
heute morgen glaube ich zumindest auf
dem Weg hier hingel gelesen New York
Times hat berichtet ja dass allein
russische Truppen der Zugang zum
Maschinenraum gehabt haben indem diese
Sprengung wahrscheinlich verfolgt oder
Erfolg ist
das zeigt im Endeffekt dass es um die
Zerstörung von oder sozusagen das
Blockieren von großen Gebieten gibt in
der die ukrainische Armee hätte halt
operieren kann
das ist schon mal weggefallen SAP wo sie
jetzt seit zwei Wochen versuchen
durchzukommen das ist einer der am
besten befestigten Linien die Russen
jetzt haben die haben mit Raketen sehr
sehr viele große Minen wie sie gerade
gesagt haben rausgebracht und großen
Flächen wo im Endeffekt jeder Schritt
irgendwie mit tödliche gefallen Soldaten
es ist im Moment tatsächlich ein
Stochern im Nebel auch für die Armee und
für die ukrainischen Armee ähm ich
glaube im Moment bleibt wirklich nichts
anderes zu gucken ja wo sie halt
durchkommen können
ich finde halt die Frage muss man auch
so ein bisschen anders stellen ehrlich
gesagt weil die Bereitschaft der
ukrainischen Gesellschaft diesen Kampf
vorzuführen die ist halt ungebrochen
hoch trotz der Erkenntnisse der
realistischen Einsicht dass es lange
dauern wird und ich glaube auf unserer
Seite stellt sich allein die Frage
unterstützen wir ohne unterstützen wir
nicht und aus moralischen Gründen finde
ich können wir nicht sagen nein können
wir nicht unterstützen weil diese
Gesellschaft ist bereit diesen Kampf zu
führen völlig zu Recht weil das was von
der anderen Seite hat einfach angetan
wird entbehrt jeglicher Grundlage für
irgendwelche Verhandlungen zu diesem
Zeitpunkt und deswegen ist das glaube
ich einfach ein Muss weiter zu
unterstützen sobald es möglich ist
lassen Sie uns über diese Unterstützung
sprechen es gibt zahlen dass die
US-Unterstützung bisher einen Wert von
110/15 Milliarden Dollar hat die
europäische Unterstützung einen Wert von
60 65 Milliarden Dollar also das sind so
die Größenordnungen
sie haben glaube ich an mehreren Stellen
angesprochen der
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf
die veränderte Stimmung in der
amerikanischen Bevölkerung können
Auswirkungen darauf haben wie stark die
Amerikaner weiter unterstützen
was bedeutet das wenn die Amerikaner
nach und nach ihre Unterstützung
zurückziehen wir aber es mit einem Krieg
zu tun haben von dem Sie alle am Tisch
sagen der wird lang und länger und da
wird es keine schnelle Entwicklung geben
was bedeutet das bedeutet dass
eigentlich alle davon ausgehen dass Joe
Biden der letzte transatlantische
Präsident Amerikas ist gleich von
welcher Partei er kommt das haben wir in
Brüssel immer wieder und das ist ja auch
der Grund weshalb die Europäer jetzt
hart daran arbeiten mehr für für die
Verteidigung für die Rüstung fürs
Militär auszugeben das sind ja ist ja
die Idee zwei Prozent von der
Wirtschaftsleistung also vom
Bruttoinlandsprodukt verlässlich zu
investieren ins Militär viele Länder
sind weiter davon entfernt von den 31
Ländern schaffen das im Moment nur
sieben deutschland gehört zu den Ländern
die das noch nicht schaffen zwei
Mittelfeld liegen aber das ist eben das
was in Deutschland Zeitenwende heißt
viel mehr Geld soll in die Rüstung
investiert werden in die Verteidigung
aber ob man dann wirklich so in dieser
Zeit die jetzt nur noch zur Verfügung
steht
auch nur aufschießen kann zu den
Amerikanern das halte ich doch für sehr
unrealistisch dass das würde solche
Milliarden zum bedeuten die die man
sicher nicht in Folge Timing wenn beiden
Präsident ist also jetzt noch in ein
zwei Jahren das kann man nicht
ausgleichen und dann dann gibt es
tatsächlich ein großes Problem das ist
diese Kippkante von der auf die Rede ist
da kann man nur hoffen dass die dass die
Amerikaner länger bleiben in Europa
ich würde es stimmt richtig die Frage
ist nur welche Anteil davon geht in die
Ukraine also wir reden jetzt im Moment
von der Kriegssituation dort und wenn
man sich jetzt anguckt wie überraschen
plötzlich der deutsche Gepard ja der
Panzer der jetzt so erfolgreich gegen
die Drohne ist im Endeffekt ausgemustert
weil das war ein Modell das jetzt auf
dem abstellstand auf einmal kriegt er
halt einfach eine ganz neue Bedeutung
ich glaube es kommt drauf an wie viel
wir von dem Teil was wir jetzt einfach
als gemeinsame europäische
Verteidigungspolitik jetzt in die
Aufrüstung stecken wie viel davon
tatsächlich dann die Ukraine kommt und
was Sie davon anfangen und damit
anfangen kann also für die Situation
dort ist das glaube ich das
entscheidende weil auf der anderen Seite
in Russland ist das ja auch so dass die
alle ihre wirtschaftlichen Ressourcen
übrigens viel schneller als die
europäischen oder westlichen Partner das
gemacht haben in diesen Krieg halt
stecken
alles konzentriert darauf deswegen würde
ich einfach dieses zwei Ziel Prozent
also sozusagen zweimal teilen was
bedeutet das für uns und das bedeutet
das konkret für die Ukraine und für die
Ukraine finde ich das einfach schon
sinnvoll was dabei passiert
also ich glaube wir haben nicht nur
moralische Flüchtlings also die haben
wir natürlich auch keinen Ball zu stehen
sondern ich glaube aus unserem eigenen
Interessen müssen wir das machen ich bin
überzeugt das Pute wenn er nur keine
Erfolg hat sie als nächstes starten wie
molder oder das Baltikum und damit der
NATO Staaten ins visieren nimmt und
und ich glaube was wir falsch machen ist
dass wir immer diese kurzfristige
Diskussion was sie auch schon
angesprochen hatten also dann
diskutieren wir bei Leopard dann
schicken wir 18 Leopard also wir müssten
viel viel langfristiger denken eben auch
vor der Erkenntnis dass dieser Krieg
nicht so weit zu Ende gehen wird und das
auch um Putin zu zeigen diese Offensive
ist nicht der Höhepunkt unserer
Unterstützung jetzt und denkbar finde
ich wäre zum Beispiel so ein Modell wie
Israel wo die Amerikaner in 10
jahresplänen festlegen wie viel sie im
Moment ich glaube umgerechnet rund 3,5
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr an Militärhilfe
Israel geben dass wir wichtig dass die
Ukraine darauf bauen kann dass sie weiß
das ist eine lange Unterstützung das
wäre wichtig dass Putin auch sieht also
die der besten verpflichtet sich dafür
eine lange Periode und macht das eben
nicht nur für seine Kurzstrecke bis er
dann vielleicht die Lust verliert
also ich glaube auch dass man auch der
westlichen Öffentlichkeit erklären muss
dass so dass das ja auch ein Krieg also
nicht nur so ein Lokal Konflikt zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine ist sondern
dass das ja wirklich also gut denen das
heißt sich begreift im Krieg gegen den
Westen und dass das eben dadurch auch
diese Bedeutung hat auch für für die
Sicherheitsarchitektur Europas aber eben
auch weltweit also ich glaube das ist
wird jetzt doch nicht so ist noch nicht
allen klar geworden glaube ich und
deswegen ist das natürlich also von
Global für die globale
Sicherheitsarchitektur wichtig also wenn
man das davon ausgeht dass die Ukraine
das sind Ukraine noch fast 20 Prozent
des Landes von Russland besetzt sind
dann das natürlich jedes Völkerrecht und
und stellt die Sicherheitsarchitektur
weltweit nach den Chancen gefragt als
Antworten habe ich sag mal die
zögerlichkeiten und die
Entscheidungsprozesse im Westen von
ihnen gehört ich lese mit was sie so
kommentieren Andreas Wetzel fragt was
ist wenn Russland gewinnt Julian Pfund
sagt wie lange kann die Ukraine noch
durchhalten wenn die Russen zwei bis
dreifache Vorräte an Munition und
kriegsgeräten haben ja also was ist wenn
Russland gewinnt weil man einen Krieg
gewinnen kann also man dachte ja
Russland gewinnt wenn wir uns mal
anschauen die Tage vor der Krieg begann
da waren ja alle ganz sicher dass
Russland die Lufthoheit über der Ukraine
in zwei bis drei Tagen erobert haben
würde und das Kiew ganz schnell erobert
sein würde dass das nicht passiert liegt
daran dass der Westen mit massiven
Unterstützung der Ukraine unter die Arme
gegriffen hat also ich sehe das
überhaupt nicht so so kritisch und und
auch gar nicht so pessimistisch die
Briten und die Amerikaner haben die
ukrainische Armee aufgerüstet seit dem
Überfall seit der Annexion der Krim der
Rest der EU hat das auch getan
Deutschland steht da inzwischen ein
zweiter Stelle es werden massiv Panzer
es wird massiv Munition und vor allen
Dingen
Abwehrraketen Abwehr Waffen geliefert
und das alles wird aufgebaut jetzt
werden ja auch Piloten ausgebildet ja
nicht damit keine Kampf Flugzeuge
geliefert werden sondern damit
Kampfflugzeuge geliefert werden und die
Tatsache dass die Ukraine bis bisher so
dass ich würde sagen erfolgreich
gekämpft hat also immer gemessen an den
Erwartungen von vor gut einem Jahr zeigt
ja dass die westliche Hilfe fruchtet
also das ist ja jetzt nicht so als würde
nichts passieren ich wollte nur kurz
sagen also ich glaube also zu Beginn des
Krieges hat ja die Ukraine da so
Großteil ist also die Russen also quasi
aufgehalten und erst dann kam die große
die große Militär für die Ukraine also
ich glaube das einfach die
die also die Macht der der russischen
Armee wurde einfach entzaubert von den
Ukrainern also man hat denken man ist
davon ausgegangen dass die viel stärker
sind dass die wirklich also dass das
Land erobern können innerhalb kürzester
Zeit und eigentlich ist das dem Kampfes
Willen also wirklich und auf dem
Widerstand der Zivilbevölkerung zu
verdanken dass das in der ersten Zeit
nicht passiert ist und erst dann in
späterer Folge kann man auch die
Militärhilfe aus dem Westen
die wir ja jetzt sehen ich glaube auch
also was man also ist ein bisschen zu
kurz gegriffen zu sagen das waren die
westlichen Waffen die Motivation der
Ukrainer ist es glaube ich ihr großer
großer Vorteil anders als die der Russen
die gar nicht wissen was sie in diesem
Land eigentlich sollen und diese
Motivation das wirklich herzzerreißen zu
sehen manchmal also wenn man da anguckt
mit den Soldaten das sind ja das sind ja
viele Freiwillige auch dabei dann und
ich meine die kämpfen um ihr Überleben
um das Überleben ihres Landes ihrer
Kultur gegen einen gegen einen
imperialistischen Diktator der sie
auslöschen möchte und das ist natürlich
noch mal eine andere Beweggrund
natürlich wäre das ohne westliche Waffen
hätten sie vermutlich am Ende verloren
ne aber was ich meinte eigentlich mit
dem westlichen Waffen ist klar wir haben
die geliefert und so immer noch sehr
mühseligen Diskussionen besonders in
Deutschland finde ich irgendwie die die
auch schlecht kommuniziert wurden weil
wir am Ende ja dann doch irgendwie
geliefert haben aber das war immer sehr
zermürmt aber das langfristige
commitment dass wir sagen in einem 10
Jahresplan die mit Israel liegen wir als
Westen uns fest wie wir die Ukraine
unterstützen das gibt es nicht ja also
vielleicht liegt das daran dass man
einen Krieg im 21 Jahrhundert nicht mit
Kampfpanzern entscheiden kann vielleicht
erleben wir das gerade dass man sich
gegenseitig einfach schwach bekämpft und
dann am Ende eine Situation entsteht in
der möglicherweise beide Seiten die
Voraussetzung für Verhandlungen gegeben
sehen dass das ist die wahrscheinlichere
Annahme denke ich als zu denken der
Landkrieg wird am Ende militärisch ganz
klar gewonnen oder verloren
das Problem ist ja ich gehe total mit ja
mit ihnen dass man sagt wir müssen am
verhandlungs sozusagen das ganze lösen
nur am
23.02.2022 er hat eine Seite entschieden
ich mache es anders er hatte Putin hatte
am 22 Februar letzten Jahres die beste
Voraussetzung die besten Deal seines
Lebens zu machen ja er hat darauf
verzichtet er dachte er kann noch mehr
sicherlich mit falschen Informationen
die seine Geheimdienste nach oben nur
die Information durchgereicht haben die
hören wollte und das würde am Ende dazu
dass eine Seite entschlossen hat doch
einen sozusagen eine geographische
Streitfrage aus russisch Ansicht mit
Kampfpanzern zu lösen und darauf dann
jetzt zu sagen also es wird halt
schwierig so eine Seite dann aufzuhalten
und ich glaube halt dass massive Gewalt
leider auch mit massiver Gewalt erstmal
gestoppt werden aus und die putin ist
nach wie vor nicht bereit ein
Verhandlungstisch zu treten es wird zwar
auch auf Twitter jetzt zu unserer
Sendung immer wieder behauptet silence
Design ich bereite aber es stimmt
einfach nicht weil man sich die
Bedingungen anguckt ja die Russland
eigentlich als Voraussetzung für eine
Verhandlung die dann sind das nicht
anders als Diktate und nur wenn Kiew
bereit sei diese schon in die Verfassung
Russlands aufgenommen Gebiete zu
akzeptieren als sozusagen nicht
ukrainische Gebiete dann könnte man über
den Rest verhandeln und was ist das für
eine Verhandlungspause ich würde gerne
einen wichtigen Aspekt bevor wir zum
Schluss auf das Thema Verhandlungen
kommen noch einbringen die Ukraine freut
sich über Unterstützung durch Waffen sie
möchte aber mehr sie möchte Mitglieder
NATO werden es gibt in Vilnius im Juli
an NATO Gipfel auf dem eine Entscheidung
dazu getroffen werden könnte die
Vorbereitungen diese Woche in Brüssel
sehen nicht danach aus dass es dazu
kommt sollte man die einfacher innen
jetzt in die NATO aufgenommen werden als
Zeichen und weitere Rückenstärkung also
ich glaube jetzt ist es vollkommen
unrealistisch weil irgendwie die USA
dagegen sind Deutschland dagegen sind
und ehrlich gesagt auch in der Ukraine
recht also ich weiß die Forderung ist
natürlich da ich glaube nicht wirklich
dass jemand ernsthaft damit rechnet dass
es passiert aber ich glaube was
passieren sollte ist in das sind
natürlich Sicherheitsgarantien das ist
und es sollte eine klare
Beitrittsperspektive jetzt geben finde
ich und wenn dieser Konflikt erstmal
wieder hoffentlich irgendwann zu einem
Stadium kommt wo er eingefroren ist wie
vor dem 24.02 was heißt Perspektive was
konkret sollte beschlossen werden aus
ihrer Sicht ein Fahrplan ein Fahrplan
was passiert sobald sobald heiße Phase
dieses Krieges abgeschlossen ist wie die
Ukraine die NATO aufgenommen werden kann
welche Aufgaben zu erledigen sind und
wenn es aus dieser heißen Phase
herausgeht dann sehe ich keinen Grund
warum die Ukraine nicht aufnehmen sollte
ich weil wir sollten nicht vergessen die
Bundesrepublik wurde 1954 aufgenommen
während des Kalten Krieges als geteiltes
Land
also ich wir hatten ja jetzt das
Verteidigungsminister Treffen in Brüssel
und da kam ganz klar raus es wird in
Vilnius im Mitte Juli beim Gipfel keine
Konkretisierung der
Beitrittsperspektive geben die gibt es
nämlich schon seit 2008 hatte die
Ukraine diese Perspektive aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen ja und ich
weiß nicht ob man ob das so klug ist
dass jetzt zu forcieren ich denke
selenski Weg der Erwartungen die nicht
erfüllt werden denn so ein Beitritt muss
ja einstimmig beschlossen werden und wir
sehen ja gerade am Beispiel Schwedens
das nur Vorteile in die Allianz bringen
würde aber gestoppt wird durch das Veto
von 1 2 Ländern durch die Türkei und
Ungarn das ist im Moment aus meiner
Sicht ganz unrealistisch zu denken dass
man einstimmig in der NATO beschließt
auch nach dem Krieg dass die Ukraine
Mitglied wird stattdessen gibt es
Sicherheitsgarantien das hat der
amerikanische Präsident ja schon
angedeutet das scheinen die auch
vorzubereiten inzwischen Deutschland ist
wohl dabei in der Bundeskanzler hat das
begrüßt Frankreich auch und dann gibt es
ja die Idee in Vilnius noch ein Angebot
zu machen dass die Ukraine Partner wird
und das sehen wir jetzt ja auch die
armeewert komplett ausgerüstet mit
westlicher auf nato-standard
produzierter Waffensystem wir haben ja
zurzeit noch aus sowjetischer Zeit viele
Waffen das passiert und dann wird es ein
NATO Ukraine Rat geben in dem und ich
würde das nicht unterschätzen indem die
Ukraine gleichberechtigtes Mitglied ist
in dem nicht nur über die Ukraine
gesprochen wird sondern auch über
transatlantische Fragen also so eine Art
Trostpflaster kann man sagen aber
vielleicht auch eine gute Ersatzlösung
für eine Übergangszeit denke gerade so
über die Sprachen nach und und überlege
ob das alle verstehen Perspektive
naturlandrat Sicherheitsgarantien
das sind alles Schöne Wörter eigentlich
Herr vom verbunden gibt es auch um die
Frage kämpft die NATO mit den Ukrainern
zur Befreiung ihres Gebietes oder bleibt
sie zu Hause und schickt nur das Gerät
dafür also das Kreml sprech ist genau
das ja wir kämpfen nicht die Ukraine wir
kämpfen gegen den Balken Westen das ist
das was nach innen dort erzählt wird und
das ist natürlich ein narrativ das auch
nach innen viel mehr auch leider auch
wirkt und Früchte trägt weil das sagt
etwas man sei widerstandsfähig man
könnte halt irgendwie gegen die mächtige
Natur halt bestehen das ist uns auch in
einer relativ das erlauben würde im
Prinzip auch nach innen zu erzählen wir
haben uns wehrhaft zusammen verteidigen
können ist größer genau ja das ist
natürlich die übliche irgendwie
mittelalterliche Erzählung ja von dem
großen Gegner
faktisch sie sind natürlich Ukraine die
kämpfen natürlich gibt's nordwestliche
Berater und westliche Aufklärung die
alles hilft aber die Motivation und das
was das Ganze trägt und diesen
Widerstand gegen den hoffentlich den
einen der letzten Tyrannen Europas hat
leistet ist das ukrainische Fall
also ich wollte da auch nur noch was
sagen zu den Erwartungen also dass der
Erwartungen geweckt werden die
vielleicht nicht erfüllt werden können
also durch die NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine
also ich glaube auch nicht dass die
Ukraine so naiv sind also die sind schon
sehr realistisch durch die Jahre
geworden weil es hieß am Anfang immer
das EU assozierungsabkommen das wird
nicht klappen dann hieß es der
EU-Beitritt
beitrittskandidatenstatus wird nicht
knapp nicht klappen seit letztem Jahr
ist die Ukraine EU Beitrittskandidat und
ähm also was ich eben auch aus der
Zivilbevölkerung höre in der in der
Ukraine ist dass die eine sehr
realistischen Blick darauf haben also
dass viele im Westen nicht auf die
Ukraine warten das wissen sie schon aber
es ist andererseits natürlich auch
verständlich dass sie Lenski sagt er
möchte den NATO Beitritt also weil das
die größte Absicherung wäre die man sich
vorstellen kann eben sie haben es
angesprochen also die der Bündnis Fall
also es gibt wahrscheinlich keinen
größere Absicherung der Ukraine gegen
die russische Aggressionen in der
Zukunft als das ob das realistisch ist
weiß ich auch nicht ich glaube die
Ukraine ist halt auch etwas
traumatisiert von diesen
Sicherheitsgarantien die
Budapester Memorandum zum Beispiel
gegeben wurden 1994 als die Ukraine die
Atomwaffen abgeben musste und im
Gegenzug gab es also westliche mächt und
auch Russland die garantiert die
Souveränität garantierten der Ukraine
und wir wissen jetzt wie viel das wert
war also ist es aus ukrainischer Sicht
glaube ich nur logisch dass die
vehemente in NATO-Beitritt wollen es ist
klar
dass Schweden Vorteile der NATO bringen
würde ich glaube ehrlich gesagt da würde
ich auch eine Lanze für die Ukraine
bringen brechen wollen weil die die
Ukrainer ist wirklich eine Kampf
erprobte Armee haben die die gegen
Russland im Kampf erprobt ist was jetzt
in unter der National
Sicherheitsstrategie der Bundesregierung
als der größte die größte Gefahr
beschrieben wurde für uns ich glaube wir
hätten dort also es wäre für die NATO
mit nicht nur von Nachteil also es wäre
nicht nur von Vater für die Ukraine also
ich glaube wir würden auch profitieren
eine solche Armee die tatsächlich Kriegs
erprobt ist und sich damit übrigens auch
ja klar an die Seite des oder für den
besten entschieden hat spätestens damit
in dieses Bündnis aufzunehmen bei allen
Schwierigkeiten die ich sehe auf dem Weg
dahin dagegen
sie hatten vorhin gesagt dass wenn die
heiße Phase vorbei seid dann sollte man
so schnell wie möglich sonst in der
Ukraine Fahrplan geben und ich glaube
das ist am Ende sozusagen der Knackpunkt
an der ganzen Geschichte solange das
System Putin und ich sage bewusst nicht
Putin sondern das System tut ja immer
macht ist wird es diese wird das ein
Ende dieser heißen Phase nicht geben
dieser
Terrorismus derjenigen die zivile
Bevölkerung immer wieder mal in Raketen
Beschuss auf den Kraftwerken Wasserwerk
eine Gasleitung und was auch immer das
wird anhalten es wird einfach so lange
weiterhin betrieben werden damit es
genau dazu nicht kommt ja damit dann 31
oder 32 NATO Mitglieder sagen okay jetzt
ist die Zeit okay jetzt könnte man
darüber reden und dann kann man nichts
da garantiert die nächste Rakete man
wird genau das verhindern danke für den
Austausch dazu wer in diesem Krieg ähm
Angreifer und wer angegriffener ist
darüber kannst keinen Zweifel geben
trotzdem die deutsche Öffentlichkeit die
uns zuhört ja sehr Unterschied weniger
Ansicht darüber wie sehr wir als
Bundesrepublik Waffen liefern die
Ukraine unterstützen am Ende durch
NATO-Beitritt sogar Teil des Konflikts
werden sollten ich glaube das was Sie
beschrieben haben Herr Miray da läuft
vielen kalt und heißt den Rücken runter
weil die Vorstellung also dass wir
Kriegspartei sind natürlich in der
Öffentlichkeit wenig Unterstützung
findet wo sich vermutlich alle oder fast
alle einig sind das ist die Sehnsucht
dass dieses Schlachten zu Ende gehen
möge sie haben das Thema
Verhandlungsbereitschaft schon
angesprochen
also wann nicht heute und nicht morgen
ganz offensichtlich aber
waren Frosch mit gibt es unter welchen
Umständen die Aussicht dass wenigstens
ein Waffenstillstand ins greifbare kommt
das weiß ich nicht ich glaube das kann
man nicht voraussagen das sind die
Voraussetzungen eine Voraussetzung wäre
dass in Moskau was passiert
möglicherweise gibt es
sich doch eine Opposition gegen Putin
dann wissen wir allerdings nicht ist das
eine die die er mit dem Westen
verhandeln will oder ist das eine die
noch einen schärferen Kurs einschlägt
die beiden Optionen gibt es ja im Moment
eine andere eine andere unbekannte in
dieser Gleichung mit vielen Unbekannten
ist wie ja wie der gefechtsverlauf
weitergeht ich denke im Moment spricht
vieles dafür dass der Krieg noch dauert
dass dass man sich weiter bekämpfen wird
in eine Art und Weise wie wir das aus
dem ersten Weltkrieg kennen wir sehen ja
wirklich Jungs und einige Soldatinnen
auch in in Gräben so wie vor Werder das
ist ja im Grunde archaisch was da im
Moment passiert wenn man sich die Videos
anschaut man schießt immer noch Granaten
in kanonenrohren von A nach B so wie vor
200 Jahren das hätte ja niemand gedacht
dass ein solcher Land kriegt noch mal
möglich ist und das ist glaube ich auch
der Grund weshalb man das jetzt so
schlecht steuern kann und niemand weiß
wie das zu Ende geht außer dass alle
warten schauen mal was auf dem auf dem
gefechtsverhältnis meiner Frage was
wären die Voraussetzungen also ich
glaube die Voraussetzung wäre dass es
einfach auf beiden Seiten eine derartige
Erschöpfung gibt dass es ja keine
Alternative gibt als zu verhandeln weil
derzeit sind wir glaube ich wirklich
noch sehr weiter vorne
das ist sehr zynisch ich hatte ein
Gespräch mit einem relativ also
silenzkinaren Politologen unlängst und
der meinte das ist das absolute Maximum
was er sich vorstellen kann dass es
vielleicht also wenn es wirklich also
wenn die Offensive nicht weitergeht wenn
beide Seiten feststecken ist wirklich
viele viele Todesopfer gibt dass es auch
in Ukraine dann die Bereitschaft gibt
zumindest über eine kurze Waffenruhe zu
verhandeln also unter den Militär also
nicht auf der Ebene selensky oder Putin
also nicht auf seiner politischen Ebene
sondern auf seine unteren aber
Friedensverhandlungen davon sind wir
glaube ich wirklich mein weit entfernt
weil das würde ja bedeuten dass es
Verhandlungen gibt über Territorien die
ja beide Seiten also natürlich die
Ukraine
zunächst ganz bescheidene Gespräche über
einen Waffenstillstand liegt es am
Vermittler China afrikanische Staaten
die Putin jetzt getroffen hat nein ich
glaube diese Vermittler also ich meine
selenski sagt ja völlig klar die Haltung
der Ukraine ist wir müssen die Russen
aus unserer Territorium herauskriegen
und dann reden wir ich finde das eine
sehr verständliche Haltung ja also ich
finde man kann einen ein
imperialistischen Diktator der einen
Nachbarland überfallen hat nicht mit
Zugeständnissen
mit Zugeständnissen belohnen eine Art
abisementpolitik betreiben also dass das
nicht funktioniert haben wir hier selber
1938 39 gesehen und der muss halt
gestoppt werden und wenn es jetzt
Friedensverhandlungen gäbe
oder selbstverhandlung über
Waffenstillstand dann würden sie diesen
Konflikt jetzt so einfrieren wie Sie
sagten 20% des Gelände sind okkupiert
von den Russen offiziell offiziell
annektiert sind noch viel mehr und
natürlich ist das für die Ukrainer
völlig in akzeptabel also ich glaube
auch das ist noch ein wirklich weiter
Weg bis dahin und ja und und selbst dann
glaube ich ehrlich gesagt wird wird
Puten im Zweifel
diese Zeit immer dafür nutzen die
Truppen neu aufzustellen und und wird
wieder angreifen wenn das Dilemma ist im
Moment einfach dass beide Seiten glauben
halt immer noch was gewinnen zu können
ja und also objektiv betrachtet hat ist
aus putinsicht auch noch was geworden
aber ein Fünftel das Landes besetzt er
hat er zwingt im Prinzip immer stärker
was Sie gesagt haben die NATO oder die
westlichen unterstütze rein putin will
eigentlich überhaupt nicht mit selensky
verhandeln oder überhaupt nicht mit der
auch nicht mit der EU er will im
Endeffekt auf Augenhöhe auf seine
Perspektive mit den Osterferien es geht
hier einfach wieder um eine
ja an Wiederherstellung das aus seiner
Sicht ja gesessen was zu Unrecht und
gebrochen werden war nämlich eine
bestimmte Rolle Russland und das ist
halt dass die Lämmer die Ukraine
wiederum ist im Moment natürlich
militärisch so stark wie nie und sie
muss
einfach jetzt erstmal Druck ausüben und
so viel wie möglich zurückerobern es gab
glaube im Dezember oder so gab es einen
wirklich sehr lesenswertes Interview mit
dem Obi Ukraine im Economist der
eigentlich zwischen den Zeilen relativ
deutlich gesagt hat wir müssen versuchen
so viel wie möglich zurück zu erobern
und dann am Ende halt irgendwie zu
verhandeln ich glaube da auch der
Ukraine ist klar das ist am Ende sehr
sehr schwierig wird alles wirklich
komplett alles inklusive der Krim sehr
schnell zurück zu bekommen aber das
heißt für jetzt gibt es eine
Rationalität auf beiden Seiten nicht
mehr Handeln im Gegenteil für bei auf
beiden beide Seiten sind in ihrer Logik
so gefangen dass sie sagen wir haben
jetzt eher was zu gewinnen die eine sagt
wir müssen jetzt Bewegung reinbringen
die andere sagt ich habe so viel
geworden ich muss das halten darf ich
eine kurze Sache noch sagen weil sie
eben Sachen das hier zuhören und zuhören
das kalt und heißt den Rücken
runterlaufen würde bei dem was ich sage
ich glaube dass die Leute die Vermutung
vermutlich ist es richtig aber ich
glaube das ist dass die Leute die die
sich gegen Waffenlieferung aussprechen
und diese Frieden bewegten leute das ist
ja durchaus nachvollziehbar und die
andere Gruppe zu der ich gehöre die sagt
wir müssen viele Waffen liefern uns
einen der dasselbe Ziel wir wollen
diesen dritten Weltkrieg verhindern wir
wollen eine weitere Eskalation verändern
wir glauben halt nur dass das
unterschiedliche Wege dahin gibt ich bin
überzeugt dass dieser Weg der richtige
ist dass man Putin stoppen muss aber
natürlich verstehe ich auch was die
andere Seite sagt
das heißt möglicherweise sitzen wir
nächstes Jahr wieder hier dann etwas
früher als im Juni und sprechen über die
nächste Frühjahrsoffensive
ja möglicherweise war das nicht die
letzte Offensive
bedanke mich für ja sag mal eine Sendung
die jetzt so gar nicht den Lichtblick
die Perspektive in Richtung Frieden
eröffnet hat aber für eine gute Analyse
die glaube ich hilft zu verstehen was da
im Moment passiert bleiben Sie gerne
dabei Presseclub nachgefragt bei Phoenix
im Radio bei WDR 5 im Netz hier bei uns
und ansonsten in der ARD viel Spaß jetzt
mit dem Europa Magazin und ja dem
Versuch einen etwas heiteren Blick in
die Ukraine zu werfen lassen sich gut
gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Radio bei WDR 5 im
Fernsehen bei Phoenix und natürlich im
Netz und wir beginnen in Münster bei
Martin Louis guten Tag willkommen in der
Sendung Martin Leu aus Münster hallo
Entschuldigung guten Tag in die Runde
und zwar geht es mir um ein gewaltloses
Mittel was immer auch hilft das sind die
Sanktionen ich kriege ja mit also ich
bin unbedingt dafür dass wir die
militärische unterstützen der Ukraine
dass wir da nicht nachlassen und darauf
achten dass
das ausreichend das tut den aufgehalten
wird diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen kann
aber ihr sollten gucken dass wir die
Sanktionen immer wieder Lücken schließen
wenn ich Unterstützung für die eine
Seite du musst ja auch heißen der
anderen Seite und diesen puddingsystem
das Wasser abzugraben nicht so dass also
der innere Widerstand schnell die innere
Armut aufgrund des Krieges zunimmt das
würde ich einfach mal gerne so einordnen
der Weise sagen angesichts der gewissen
Ratlosigkeit erwischt und die wir auf
der militärischen Seite ja auch erleben
ja danke ist ein Thema dass wir heute
ausgespart haben
möchte jemand erwidern dazu oder lassen
wir das einfach als Beobachtung stehen
also ich kann keine 9 Uhr nur recht
geben das Schließen der der
Schlupflöcher ist sehr wichtig wir haben
ja jetzt einige Meldungen darüber
bekommen dass die eigentlich verbotenen
Produkte die wichtig sind für
Russland dorthin kommen über die Türkei
also das ist ganz wichtig das zu
schließende arbeiten die Europäer daran
allerdings da muss ich ein bisschen auch
die Erwartungen dämpfen es hat
eigentlich niemand geglaubt dass das den
Krieg nun beeinflussen würde die
Sanktionen wirken immer sehr langfristig
wenn sie überhaupt wirken man hat ja
jetzt den Eindruck es wird schon ein
bisschen aber das ist das ist eher eine
Hoffnung eine Investition in die Zukunft
würde man vielleicht an der Börse sagen
das tritt nicht sofort ein und das wird
den Kriegsverlauf fürchte ich nicht
direkt beeinflussen danke Herr lol alles
Gute nach Münster Gotha in Thüringen ist
unsere nächste Station Michael Salz hat
willkommen im Presseclub
schönen guten Tag hallo
ich möchte einen Kommentar zu dem für
das Drehung des Stau damals mal gegen in
ihrem ersten Satz haben sie sofort
ausgeschlossen
dass etwas anderes sein könnte
durch Russland oder Unfall wenn ich
ukrainischer general wäre und ich müsste
über den Mikrofon übersetzen ich müsste
auf
monatelange Verteidigungslinien stoßen
der die Sprengung des staudampfs sorgt
dafür dass genau diese Linien alle ja
überschämt werden dass die ganzen
Panzersperren nicht da sind
warum wird immer ausgeschlossen dass die
Ukraine diesen Stadion gestreckt hat
obwohl die militärischen Vorteile aus
meiner Sicht relativ deutlich sind ja
danke dass Sie das Ansprechen also ich
habe die Möglichkeiten zitiert die ich
die ich lese aber die Frage warum ist
das nicht anders auch möglich warum kann
die Ukraine das nicht im Kalkül gehabt
haben ist eine gute also ich würde also
natürlich wissen genau kann es auch
nicht unabhängig verifizieren oder
das jetzt herausfinden aber ich glaube
es gibt schon eines eine Summe von
Plausibilitäten und
dieser Stauraum ist eben in der Gewalt
der russischen Besatzer schon sehr lange
und es gibt eben viel Experten die
meinten also dieser Stauraum ist eben so
massiv gebaut dass das so in der Sowjet
Zeit dass das wirklich unmöglich ist das
von außen quasi zu springen und selbst
wenn jetzt eine ukrainische
samotagegruppe da unterwegs gewesen wäre
bräuchte das auch eine wahnsinnig lange
Vorbereitung und eine Wahnsinn lange
also die wahrscheinlich nicht der
realistisch ist unter dieser unter den
Bedingungen der Besatzung und ich möchte
auch nur daran erinnern dass im Oktober
schon selenski darauf hingewiesen hat
bzw gefordert hat ein internationale
Beobachtermission zu Entzündung zu
diesem Staudamm also das ist schon
damals also die Befürchtung gab dass da
ähm also Sprengfallen angebracht werden
und so weiter also natürlich wissen wir
es nicht und natürlich gibt's viele
Vorteile und so weiter aber ich glaube
Russland kontrolliert diesen Stau dann
schon seit über einem Jahr experten
sagen es ist schwer das einfach also
durch Beschuss von außen zu zerstören
und sie lässt sich ja schon lange darauf
hingewiesen dass es die dass diese
Gefahr droht
das sind die Indizien die wir in spontan
in der Hunde anbieten können aber ja ja
russischer generell wäre dann wird euch
die würde ich doch den Stau dann erst
dann springen wenn russische ukrainische
Truppen auf der anderen Seite sind
die müssen durch die
hauptverteilungslinie durchdringen es
gibt riesenverlusten wenn ich dann den
Staudamm springe das ist Nachschub
abgeschnitten dann ja die Truppen sofort
vernichtet oder sie ergeben sich also
den Teig den Staudamm zu diesem
Zeitpunkt zu springen
kann ich nicht nachvollziehen ja danke
dass ihr das mit uns geteilt haben die
Lösungen liegt halt nicht in der Frage
was logisch gewesen wäre sondern
wirklich in Ermittlungen im Suchen von
Indizien beweisen und oft ist es ja bei
Kriegsverbrechen so dass man dann lange
Zeit später wirklich Beweise auch hat
also danke dass sie da eingehakt haben
Herr Gotha ich glaube das ist auch
anderen durch den Kopf gegangen
und dann gehen wir nach Niebüll in den
Norden zu Helmut yasular guten Tag
hallo
moin moin
sie sind dran ja
ich wollte nur noch mal den Punkt
erwähnen das Putin auf Augenhöhe
verhandeln wird und zwar nur mit der
US-Administration ja und da ist die
Frage wann wird die
usa-ministration bereit sein sich auf
solchen Verhandlungen einzulassen um
noch mal auf den Herrn rechten Hand
kennen zu sprechen zu kommen
die man im Nahen Osten hat
Israel alles Klima dann kann ich nur
sagen dass es ärmlich bis zu erwerblich
ich hoffe dass es irgendwann keine
besser geht danke
Herr Funk sie hatten das ja angesprochen
das Putin nicht mit seinem Kriegsgegner
sondern mit den USA verhandeln möchte
die Frage von Herrn jaskula war ja wann
würde das tun
im Moment sehe ich überhaupt nicht das
Washington die Bereitschaft zeigt das zu
tun ja und das aus guten Gründen also
wenn wir uns von ich sag mal jedem der
hat bestimmte Spielregeln internationale
Spielregeln brechen will da erpressen
lassen wer mit wem miteinander halt
verhandelt dann wird das irgendwann sehr
schwierig einfach da überhaupt irgendwie
ein internationale Regelwerk zu
erarbeiten ja gut das ist potenziell das
was sie auch am Anfang gesagt hatten
Frau Schmidt ja dass das neben der
Eroberung Kies auch sozusagen Gespräche
mit der NATO mit den USA vor allen
Dingen geführt werden sollten es wird
aber schwierig sein dann überhaupt
international Regeln irgendwie
durchzusetzen wenn irgendeiner der sagt
nie passen mir aber nicht ja so ein
erpressungsszenario aufbaut und dann
halt gesagt ich verhandel aber dann nur
mit den mächtigsten dieser Welt ich
glaube schon das Putin am Ende mit denen
verhandeln bzw putin wird nicht
verhandeln ja das wird halt andere für
ihn halt erledigen mit dem Land bei dem
sie Verbrechen begehen ja lassen Sie ein
bisschen schwieriger nur eine Antwort
damit möglichst viele zu Wort kommen und
ich merke dass das Thema Verhandlungen
viele beschäftigt auch Peter hufschroer
in Bernau in Brandenburg Beruf guten Tag
ja
schönen guten Tag in die Runde ich
glaube das Putin sich innerhalb
seines Landes innerhalb von Russland
nicht mehr sehr lange halten kann
es gibt sehr viele oppositionelle Kräfte
es gibt sehr viele Menschen die auch
Angst vor diesem Regime haben und es
gibt auch Leute die derzeit mit dem
russischen Geheimdienst soweit
zusammenarbeiten dass sie sagen wir
brauchen auch eine Zeit nach Putin und
wir wollen internationale Reputation
zurückgewinnen und ich glaube dass
irgendwann Protein von Russland gestürzt
sein wird und dann vielleicht doch noch
vor den Internationalen Gerichtshof
kommt verhandeln muss man mit Russland
ganz klar aber nicht mit Putin und
seinen Komplizen dann hätte man auch mit
Göring verhandeln können oder ähnliches
das ist sinnlos
er ruft danke für Ihre Meinung ähm
glaub lassen das so stehen weil
Funk gesagt hat schon in der Sendung
dass er die Einschätzung nicht ganz
teilt das Putin bald die Macht verliert
so habe ich es verstanden oder also es
ist tatsächlich sehr schwierig es gibt
politische Login also ich habe letztens
ein Gespräch mit einer jetzigen Exil
lebenden russischen Politologen die sagt
einerseits deuten sehr viele Zeichen
darauf hin dass die Macht immer
instabiler wird weil die Rückseite das
System sehr viel Aufwand betreiben muss
um die Macht zu stabilisieren ja aber
andererseits sozusagen diesen
in dem Moment wo es wirklich irgendwie
Knackpunkte gibt den sehe ich nicht und
Russland hat also das potent hat
wahnsinnig viel auch Kraft aufgewendet
um sich zu stabilisieren ja also diese
repressionsmaschine und wir dürfen
einzelne System das 70 Jahre Erfahrung
mit Repressionen hat ja er hat halt
einfach eine ganze Latein
Anwendungsmöglichkeiten wir macht sich
hat ja und das ist klar das ist halt
einfach ein Riesener
danke
sie sind schon aus der Leitung aber
danke dass Sie dabei waren
ja ich würde sagen wir gehen mal nach
edersleben zu Jürgen Fuchs herr Fuchs
guten Tag ich weiß dass viele Hörerinnen
und Zuschauer verzweifelt versuchen
durchzukommen aber ich glaube wir haben
schon ein oder zweimal miteinander
gesprochen sie haben den Dreh offenbar
raus bitte sie sind dran guten Tag an
die Hunde meine Frage ist dahin gehen
ist es nicht höchste Zeit dass man
gerade auch in ihrer Sendung über
Varianten der sofortigen
kriegseinstellung in der Ukraine
diskutiert Varianten Waffenstillstand
diplomatische Verhandlung und und und
und also breitesten Rahmen
einstelle über Varianten der
Waffenlieferungen
der offensiven von Ukraine und Erfolgen
und Misserfolgen denn das ist doch das
Wichtigste was man sich vorstellen kann
wir sind ja alle eingestellt Ruhe in der
Welt zu haben und Ihre Sendung Herr
Schönborn hat breiteste Wirkung
vielleicht haben Sie Glück und einem
Politiker hört zu wenn es interessante
Varianten der Diskussion von
Journalisten mit ihnen gibt
so viel erstmal danke für den Impuls
Frau Schmidt sie ja ich finde das Wort
sofortige kriegseinstellung fantastisch
das würden sich alle Politiker und auch
wie hier sofort unterschreiben ich
fürchte das geht nicht ohne
Waffenlieferungen das ist ganz klar aus
einer Position der Stärke könnte man
verhandeln und ich bin auch gar nicht so
pessimistisch ich glaube es es gibt ja
immer noch Verhandlungen zum Beispiel
über die Getreide Lieferung es gibt
Verhandlungen regelmäßig in der
Öffentlichkeit gar nicht so wahrgenommen
über
Kriegsgefangenen über Soldaten
austauscht das funktioniert gut und da
könnte man drauf satteln und und einen
kleinen Punkt nach dem anderen
abarbeiten denn wenn man sich anschaut
wie Kriege zu Ende gegangen sind in den
vergangenen Jahren niemals dass ich
irgendwo die Kriegsherren getroffen
hätte und und andere unterschreibt eine
Kapitulationsurkunde so geht das nicht
mehr sondern man muss ganz ganz klein
anfangen Vertrauen aufzubauen daran
arbeiten zurzeit viele Diplomaten und
wir hören davon nicht so viel das liegt
daran dass sie offensichtlich alle
scheitern ändert aber nichts daran dass
das der einzige Weg ist rauszukommen aus
diesem Krieg herr Fuchs ich behalte
ihren Appell im Hinterkopf alles Gute
Gruß nach edersleben und ganz in der
Nähe hier in Köln ist Peter Karp in der
Leitung hallo
Peter gab aus Köln 80 Jahre alt ich habe
folgende Frage an die Damen und Herren
die wirklich hier näher dran sind
Europa hat 516 Millionen Einwohner haben
wir die Engländer wieder dazu zählen
dann kommen die Amerikaner mit 360 dann
kommt Australien Japan Schweden Finnland
etc also ich glaube dass wir Isolierung
auf 1,2 Milliarden Leute kommen mit
einer riesen Wirtschaftskraft der Russe
der Putin hat 143 Millionen Leute ich
verstehe voll und es nicht man hält
durch dieses
zilgerliche Unterstützung das ist ja
sicherlich vorhanden aber ist es denn
eine gute Strategie durch einen
zögerliches unterstützen deswegen dauern
D am Kochen zu halten anstatt ist zu
beenden ich glaube dass das sowohl was
jetzt die Menschenleben Mann betrifft
als auch den ganzen materiellen Aufwand
und so weiter und wir kämpfen ja hier
überhaupt über eine Weltanschauung
zusammen mit der Ukraine Ukraine es geht
ja darum glaube
zentralverwaltungswirtschaften irgendwie
geografisch klein zu halten also ich
verstehe nicht warum man nicht mit
stärkeren Mitteln das einfach beendet
ja könnten die Experten dazu oder einer
davon
angesetzt ja genau also ich teile Ihre
Meinung da ich finde auch dass es zu
zögerlich wie das geschehen ist das ist
ein Problem ich meine wir haben als
deutsche angefangen mit 5000 Helmen
damit haben wir uns ehrlich gesagt
lächerlich gemacht in Kiew von den
Washington jetzt sind wir immerhin bei
Kampfpanzern aber ich finde auch dass es
zu langsam gegangen immer mit mit
quälenden Diskussionen und man hätte
sicherlich früher mehr liefern können
und müssen und hätte damit glaube ich
auch tatsächlich tote verhindert ich
glaube jetzt sind wir im ganzen Schritt
weiter gekommen ich hoffe dass das so
bleibt aber ich hatte jetzt in der
Sendung ja auch dafür geworben eben
langfristige sicherheitszusagen zu
machen also langfristige hilf zu sagen
Unterstützung zu sagen auch zu machen
damit die Ukraine eben weiß worauf sie
bauen kann weil im Moment ist es so dann
sagt ein Land mal diese Leopard Panzer
zu die Amerikaner sagen Bradleys zu dann
kommen vielleicht F16 oder Sie kommen
nicht aber das ist alles so Stückwerk
und ich glaube als Westen wenn wir gut
beraten wenn wir eben da feste Zusagen
geben würden auf die sich so keine
langfristig verlassen kann und ich
glaube dass wir eben auch ein Signal an
Putin dass wir sagen wir stehen da nicht
für eine offensive noch zur Verfügung
und dann vielleicht doch nicht mehr
sondern wir sagen wir stehen an der
Seite der Ukraine egal was du machst
weil man übermächtig ist okay danke für
den Austausch Gruß nach Köln
Frau Schmidt Einsatz 8 Sekunden kann ich
ihnen geben zur Frage von Ulrich
mandlmaier aus Kulmbach ob die
Geschlossenheit des Westens zunehmen
oder abnehmen wird
die bleibt so wie sie ist und das ist
eine positive Entwicklung auch ein
Überraschung die Geschlossenheit ja
trotzdem liefert der Westen so viele
Waffen so viel Unterstützung in die
Ukraine wie in kein anderes Land zuvor
bedanke mich sehr herzlich für ihre
Argumente und Beobachtung für ihren
Sachverstand wünsche Ihnen alles Gute
eine schöne Woche Gruß aus Köln lassen
sich gut gehen
[Musik]
Unter den Linden das politische
Streitgespräch aus dem Herzen der
Hauptstadt
kontrovers sachlich und mit genügend
Zeit für jedes Argument der konstruktive
Meinungsstreit Unter den Linden morgen
22:15 Uhr bei Phoenix
es war kein Lehrstück des politischen
Handwerks die Debatte um das Gebäude
Energiegesetz oder haarwerks heizhammer
wie manche gesagt haben sie hat